[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN PENAGOS: The Guardians have
returned for Marvel Studios'
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3.
And you know what that means.
Our favorite CGI pals
are back together.
That's right, I'm talking
about Rocket and Groot.
And I'm here with VFX
supervisor Stephane Ceretti
to find out how one of the
MCU's most beloved pairs
is brought to the big screen.
Hi Steph, how are you?
STEPHANE CERETTI: Hey Ryan,
I'm very good, thank you.
RYAN PENAGOS: Steph,
you were the VFX
supervisor all the way
back on the first Guardians
of the Galaxy film.
What was it like
to get to introduce
Groot and Rocket to the MCU?
When we first introduced
them in the first film,
they were such weird
characters that nobody
was really expecting.
There's that kind of weird
dynamic between the two of them
that makes them
iconic and you can get
attached to them quite quickly.
Now, in this third
Guardians film,
we dive even deeper
into these characters.
What was it like telling
their stories through VFX?
It's a very emotional
film, this one.
There's all these little
moments that really create
depth into the character.
They're not just like
animated characters.
They're really part of the cast.
So when you begin
work on the film,
how are the actors'
performances captured on set?
We're not using
mocap with the hundreds
of cameras and all that stuff.
We do reference shoot.
So we have the actors
there with us there.
We're filming the scenes.
And we then give it
to the animators.
And it's hand animated,
literally hand animated.
So it's a lot of artistry
that comes into this.
It's not at all a process
that is automated.
So we've really shot the entire
scenes on a virtual set where
we could actually capture the
motion of the camera, which was
very important for James
to use in our full CG
scenes, the same type
of camera operation
that we use throughout the
film to make it seamless
with the rest of the film.
We have an actor playing Rocket.
We have some
stand-ins for Groot.
And that was really
helpful, actually, for us.
We ended up using these
references quite a lot,
actually, even
sometimes to the point
where we add little moments
where there's eyes rolling.
And once you have the
actors' performances,
what additional visual
reference do you
capture while you're on set?
We have to shoot what we call
clean plates so that we can
paint out the
actors that are not
supposed to be here and replace
them by all our CGI characters.
So we 3D scan all the sets.
We capture the light with
what we call light probes.
We also add a company called
Legacy that worked with us
and created 3D versions
from the drawings
from this depth of how
these characters would look
with perfect fur and
all the mechanical arms
and things like that so that
we could have a good reference
on set in terms of lighting.
So that what we can do then is
really recreate in the computer
a virtual representation
of the real world
in terms of lighting,
in terms of the space,
in terms of
everything that the CG
actors have to interact with.
When we integrate our
characters within the plate,
everything feels
seamless and they
feel like they belong to the
environment they're shot in.
OK, so you've gathered
all that reference.
How do you then actually go
about creating and integrating
the CG characters?
The characters are so
different from humans.
We need to be able to
actually take that performance
from the actor and
really translate
it into the bones and the
skeleton of these animals.
We have a lot of shots that are
like close-ups on their eyes.
And there's a lot
of emotion going.
So we really worked on the
detail of the pupil, the iris,
everything, the eyes, the way
the eyelids are kind of pushing
opening the color, the level
of darkness around the eyes,
the wetness in the eyes.
When you see a CG character
animated, especially
one with fur, there's a lot
of things involved in that
that are extremely complicated.
So if there's wind, we
need to have a little bit
of wind in the fur.
If there's two CGI characters
touching each other,
we need to do, you know,
the fur kind of getting
displaced by the motion.
For Groot, when he's more young,
his face is more malleable when
you've seen him as Baby Groot.
But as he grows to
become more of a tree,
we wanted to bring that
kind of level of expression
that was kind of very
detailed in the first film.
All these little details
are helping us really bring
the moments where it
needs to be funny,
the moments where we
need to have the emotion.
Once we've shot this, we
start dropping very simple
models of the characters.
And then we get
into what we call
blocky animation at
the render, which
is a very rough animation.
But it's a little
bit more detailed.
And then as we push through, we
start getting better animation,
more finished animation.
We start getting renders.
It's a very long process.
It's not something you press
a button and you get it.
You have to have a very
talented animator and FX team.
Everyone is clearly
so freaking talented.
Steph, looking back
at all of your work
throughout the
Guardians franchise,
how does it feel to get
to bring the story of
these characters full circle?
It's been very
gratifying to go
back to the origin of Rocket and
Groot and telling that story.
Because that was a huge focus,
obviously, for me and my teams
on the first film, to make sure
that these characters would
be able to carry the story.
And now that Rocket is
really the centerpiece
of this third film, it puts
a lot of pressure on us.
But also, it's very
gratifying to see
the result coming together.
Steph, thank you so
much for joining me.
Oh, that was a pleasure.
Thank you so much
for inviting me.
Any time.
And everyone out
there, go experience
Rocket and Groot
in Marvel Studios'
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3 in theaters now.